so religion and god give a lot of
meaning to a lot of people it's it gives
a
tradition that brings people
together
um
across the generations but also can hurt
people
what do you make about that tension
so a source of meaning
but also a source of pain for people
the reality is at least to me again this
is just my reality
i feel like i'm doing my dad's thing
every time i'm talking to i'm like i
don't really know my two seconds here's
my two sets you have become your father
yeah um
the reality and it's my reality and it
is the reality for sure
there's i think that
religion has brought a lot of hurt and
pain to a lot of people
absolutely it has that i don't think
anybody can dispute that on it on either
side
um
whether it's war
um you know whether it's
slaughtering of entire peoples like it's
there's been a lot of pain and suffering
that has come from religion
um
so my little thing that has been hard
for me is a faith crisis right i had
religion and then i i lost it then i had
nothing so that's for me i was like well
religion did that to me right like
but then at one point it's kind of like
how much of my life am i just gonna
complain about like being raised mormon
or being depressed like you know as i
get older i'm like okay
so what like okay it's really hurt me
but
were there any good things that came out
of mormonism well yeah there's a lot of
good things that have come to my family
through mormonism
closeness we're really really close
mormons culture is that you live
together forever right the teaching is
that you're in your families are forever
we die and then we go to heaven together
and we're together forever my family
really believes that principle all of
them do
and that instills a certain way of
living that's kind of beautiful
even if it's naivety
there's something kind of beautiful
about
believing that we're forming these bonds
together as a family and that like we're
gonna be together forever it brings a
lot of comfort to a kid too when i was
little i was like wow
it's gonna be okay if i die because i
get to see my mom again you know i mean
i like i really believe that
is the right answer that you tell that
kid
actually when you die you're not gonna
see your mom again
maybe it might be i don't know and
everybody's gonna anybody who has a kid
is gonna face that
that moment i've already faced it where
you sit down and my kid was like hey dad
when you die am i gonna see you again
that was actually a really hard moment
for me because i was suddenly faced with
okay do i give the answer that i thought
was [ __ ]
or do i give the answer of what i think
it is or do i give the real answer which
is i don't know
and that's what i chose which is a
father that's not always the easiest
answer because your kid it's a wonderful
thing that you feel like you can give
your kid the comfort of like hey your
parents are going to take care of
everything we know everything we've been
around my kids always like are you the
strongest i'm like yeah i am the
strongest we're stronger than everybody
yeah yeah
so
when you're faced with that moment it's
like it kind of sucks to tell your kid
like you know what
i don't know if you're gonna see me
after i die
but that but i hope that's why i said i
was like i don't know but but i hope i
really hope because that would be
awesome if we can hang out forever
and if there's any way for it to happen
i'll make it happen you know what i mean
that's kind of what my answer was
so long story short
sorry i know that i'm being lengthy on
this
is there like what is my thought on
religion it just is it's gonna it's been
here forever it's coping it maybe it's i
can't say whether it's true or false how
the hell am i supposed to know
i mean like i've lived 34 years on this
planet a lot of people have been around
a lot longer than me and they really
believe very deeply and a lot of them
are smarter than me you know what i mean
like i look at my older brothers for
instance who are very practicing
mormons these guys are hyper intelligent
my my younger sister hyper intelligent
all of them start smarter than me they
all believe it still so what am i
supposed to say
well you're all stupid you know what i
mean like you're all wrong i don't know
maybe like maybe it's the south park
episode where everybody dies and then
they're like
well the right answer was mormonism
i mean like
mormon mormons love that moment in south
park they're like hey that day may
day they come
you